here's a quick overview of our free
motivation program con kickoff let's
start with the challenge which is that
motivating students right now is just
super hard
with everything going on in the world
getting students to show up and engage
day after day is no easy feat
but teachers did report one bright spot
from the fall which was the power of
teamwork
specifically hundreds of educators told
us that having students work together to
make progress in learnstorm got their
classes to show up and work hard even
during incredibly tough times
so con kickoff builds on that same sense
of camaraderie to get your students
energized this winter here's how it
works
so all you have to do
is go to your activity overview and on a
weekly basis copy in your students
progress right into your progress
tracker and then you set up your teams
either within your classroom breaking
into groups competing against other
periods or even other classrooms
and then you celebrate your progress
with the big reveal the scoreboard and a
chance to celebrate
and that celebration includes custom
certificates
with each student being acknowledged on
their own personalized certificate
as well as the ability for you as the
teacher to take your own little victory
lap and show off with your certificate
to your fellow educators
and when you do that you're going to be
automatically entered into our giveaway
which
features 10 prize packs that include a
wacom drawing tablet just like the one
that sal khan uses
and a 100 gift card so you can
commission your own celebration videos
from top athletes and performers
and best of all con kickoff is free and
open to all educators so feel free to
dive in today